Dự thảo các phân kện chình đại hội đại điều toàn Quốc lên thứ 4 của đàn, đã được công bố để lấy ý kiến đóng có của nhân dân.
Huyện việc lấy ý kiến đang diễn ra sôi nổi trên cả nước.
Trong đó, có rất nhiều đám có tâm viết, chắc giật, được ử dưới tới với mọi muốn,
có phần hoặc định đường lối phát triển của đất nước trong sai bận mới.
Dự thảo báo cáo chính trị đại hội 4 đại đại đại gia một tiêu.
Phần đấu đặt tốt đột tăng trường tổng sản phẩm trong nước GDP.
Bình quân cho sai đoạn 2 in không trạm hai miso, 2 in không trạm 3 mới,
từ mưa phân trăm 1 năm trở lên, nông thời cũng chỉ gió,
sắc lập mô hình tăng trường mới, cơ cấu lại nền tình đế,
đời mạnh công nghiệp hóa, thiền đại hóa, lấy khó học công nghệ,
lời mới sáng tạo và chuyển đổi số làm đất lực chính.
Nội dung này nhận được nhiều ý kiến mai tò sự ki vọng và tinh tường.
Bình thẳng trịnh khoảng công nghệ,
trong cái thịt quyền số này,
trong ý dụng số, thì nó nào có được phản và tụi thành đỏ,
đừng được tháng, gió thể đứt, chào cái dụng thậm chị.
Nó là tôi thấy rằng là có những cái bầu dung mà quan điểm,
bôi được chỉ tò vị thương tốt đâm,
như vào lộ dung phát triển cho mà kẹp,
có những đó bự quên trọng,
là mà đưa những kẹp, phát triển cho các dinh mới.
Và khi số là họ sẽ tạo chiếm, chỉ sẽ tìm tế rất là trang,
sau khi tìm tình thân,
thì là thì dạng là ngày hai người tư,
thì sẽ tạo chiếm, thì hai người phát triển,
cho khi tình thân tìm đồ vào bệ phân trạm,
tởi các bà là,
thì thì nó chúng ta trọng thầm tư,
thì nó phát triển cho tăng trạm để sốt.
Thì cái mức dưới đăng trạm hay không số,
là có khá đi khá hợp.
Với đi nhìn thấy,
thì có rất là bởi vì mình có kê sửa đăng trạm.
Hãy có sốt, là cạnh thiệt.
Nhìn kíu sự thảo các phát triển đại hội
đại biểu phản quốc lần thứ mấy bốn của đăng.
Như ý kiến cho rằng sau với các kỳ đại hội gần đầy,
điểm mới của bảo cáo chính trị là này,
là sự tích hợp lội dụng bà phàn kẹp,
gồm, bảo cáo chính trị,
bảo cáo chính trị xá hội,
bảo cáo tồng kết xây dự đàn,
việc tích hợp này,
thề hẹp tinh thần tiếp tục lỗi mở về các xây dựng văn kẹp.
Tì năm nay thì trong văn kẹp của chúng ta thấy là
các chi tiêu đối với giữa sàng,
cụ thể,
và có mặc ở chiến trịnh đậu,
và các bạn kẹp ở giữa sốt tích,
nếu như thế này cho thấy là khi sự trịnh trịnh trù
và hợp tâm nhất của
phải remain chỗ miningès,
tỷ văn lên đường vais mirand
được Exchange print xe tìm th Angular
otur để khoảng 30%
trên kh cyc bệnh nghiệt và tình vừa
để được phát triển bên bướcwali
Nhìn người mời.